dr. strange you think you know how the
world works what have I told you the
reality you know is one of many cool
let's do it
hello internet welcome to film theory
debunking magic one fairy at a time
there's a hole in the hat for the rabbit
cards behind his hand duh there's two
people in the box
he's walking unpleasant glass I mean
honestly the only magic trick I truly
can't figure out is how Chris angel
still has a career in short everything
can be explained through science which
brings us to the subject of the day dr.
strange also known by its other titles
now you see me three we promised jesse
eisenberg isn't in this one or its other
other title conceptions in the trailer
we see a whole bunch of crazy images dr.
strange shooting out rings of green
lights from his hands manifesting
crystal walls lassoing light whips weave
it's the entire city shifting and
protruding out of each other upside down
sideways and diagonal seriously it's
like Marvel watched inception and we're
like what one upside down city tribe or
that is the power of Disney here's
the rub from the get-go Marvel has sold
its more fantastical elements as pure
science Captain America's the result of
a science experiment gone wrong the Hulk
is the product of gamma radiation
ant-man reduces the empty space between
atomic particles something we've already
debunked even Thor complete with his
rainbow bridges is explained away as
highly advanced technology your
ancestors called it magic and you call
it science well I come from a place
where they're one and the same thing in
fact this focus on science over
quote-unquote magic has been confirmed
by none other than the head of Marvel
Studios himself Kevin Feige whoa are you
watching the Cosmo series that's magic
it's unbelievable if somebody knew how
to tap into that stuff what's the
difference between that and magic sure
in the comics Doctor Strange derives all
his powers from magical and mystical
entities but Feige has stated the film
version will be a departure from the
comics explaining the doctors powers not
with magic but science again to quote
Kevin Feige there are a couple lines in
Thor basically saying that magic and
science get to a point where what's the
difference and we're continuing that in
Doctor Strange so by coming down firmly
on the side of science Feige has
revealed that actually everything in
Doctor Strange can be explained through
reason and logic but wholly rusted Iron
Man guys how do you explain away light
shields and upside down cities even
Feige acknowledges that dr. strange
doesn't quite know himself to use one
more quote from the guy particularly for
a character like strange who goes for
a man of science - a man of faith and
who traverses both worlds and sometimes
there won't be an answer sometimes he'll
want an answer how is this happening and
nothing well unlike Feige in the rest of
Marvel Studios I matpat from film theory
I'm not gonna be leaving you hanging
anymore Benedict Cumberbatch
explaining the strange magic of Doctor
Strange is my challenge today believe it
or not all of it is possible with the
power of quantum mechanics
so before we hop into analyzing the
movie let's start with a quick quantum
mechanics overview teaching you in a few
seconds concepts that overturned
centuries of established physics
knowledge basically up until 1900
scientists believed the universe ran on
a standard laws jump off an object and
fall to ground push an object to the
right and it moves to the right
ask JJ Abrams to direct a movie and
he'll fill it with a bunch of lens
flares and some big twists in the final
half-hour these are the fundamental laws
of nature but at the beginning of the
1900 scientists discovered exceptions to
the established rules specifically
subatomic particles like electrons and
neutrons the building blocks of atoms
these particles often contradicted the
physical world as we understood it one
of the biggest developments came in 1909
basically this was the year when Albert
Einstein proposed the wave particle
duality of lights in order to explain
some pretty funky results scientists
were getting when testing light in the
lab Einstein proposed that maybe light
sometimes acted like a wave which is how
everyone thought of it at the time but
then also other times acted more like a
particle just like an electron or a
proton it's a bit confusing but it's
important to understand for today's
episode so let me quickly explain the
difference
imagine a calm pond with leaves on the
surface when you drop a stone into the
water it makes a series of circular
waves which when they reach the leaves
cause them to bob up and down but
otherwise the leaves stay in the same
position they don't actually follow the
wave it's the same thing with the water
particles the wave moves through them
but doesn't actually carry the particles
along with it this roughly illustrates
the difference between waves and
particles a particle has mass and other
measurable properties like charge while
waves don't waves typically but not
always need to move through some other
medium that's why for instance in space
no one can hear you scream
no sound because there's no air for the
sound waves to move through but that
brings us back to lights basically light
has shown itself to possess energy and
momentum which are properties of
particles and not waves and yet light
has no mass which is like rule number
one for anything that behaves like a
particle
so basically Einstein said fine otball
hit what is very obviously a bad
rendition of a german accent which in
turn prompted physics to turn on his
head in 1929 Gilbert Lewis named these
massless light particles photons and
thus quantum mechanics was born so why
do we need to cover all that well
because photons and their crazy
properties are the basis of dr.
Strange's magical powers throughout the
film dr. strange uses light both as an
offensive weapon as well as a defensive
tool manifesting Mondelez of light as a
shield to move and repel objects
it's crazy rights though maybe not so
much you can in fact move objects using
only lights you know the wind blows into
a sail and pushes it forward well you
can actually do something similar with
light because as we just discussed light
has momentum so let me introduce you to
solar sails large light weight mirrored
surfaces currently being used in space
to move objects long distances basically
the light hits one side of the sail
which has a mirrored surface that mirror
reflects away the photons coming from
the Sun but in the process the momentum
of the photons is transferred to the
sail just like wind on a boat and in
space where there's no friction to slow
you down those small bits of momentum
start to build up and that's only one
way that light can move objects there's
also what's known as the photo phoresis
effect when an atom is heated on one
side by photons the gas molecules on
that side of the particle get super
excited we're in the sunlight we're
gonna get a great tan that causes them
to move faster and as a result they
bounce off that side of the particle
surface at a higher velocity creating a
force that pushes that atom away from
the light and this isn't just
speculation scientists have recently
tested the photo freeze this effect on
tiny objects moving nails beads and even
blocks with nothing but the power of
lights so how does this apply to eggs
benedict well throughout dr. strange we
see this on a massive scale for instance
in this moment from the trailer we see
the villain castelia Sehorne as the ball
of light that essentially
pushes the particles of dr. strange and
the rest of the building outward in
other words the front half of Benedict
heats up really quickly from the intense
light and the photo phoresis effect does
the rest causing a ripple effect as
objects repel outward towards lower
illuminated areas what's happening on
the atomic level is that the gases
around the Benedict's cumberbund face
particles are getting so excited with
this intense light energy that they
start hitting him with an intense amount
of velocity so much velocity in fact
that he gets sent flying against the
wall but photons aren't just limited to
moving matter they can also create
matter that's right objects made from
massless light particles seems like it
makes no physical sense and yet in a
recent study Harvard and MIT students
managed to coax photons to binding
together into molecules per scientist
Mikhail Lucan quotes they created a
special medium in which photons
interacted so strongly that they began
to act as though they had mass and
banded together end quotes the end
results like creating three-dimensional
structures like crystals sound familiar
well it should because dr. strange is
filled with crystal imagery
for instance when dr. strange first
meets the ancient one the first thing he
sees is light coming from a crystal like
pattern theirs doesn't make any sense
well actually dr. it makes perfect sense
the photonic light tangles itself up
with the atoms in the air so much so
that the properties of the atom get
passed on to the photons at that point
the photons basically become an atom
creating solidified light a light
crystal what you're walking through is a
light crystal that is being shattered
and if that just sounds like a weird
theory a weird scientific theory it's
actually happened in real life as a
group of scientists back in 2013 already
created solidified crystals made purely
of light forget Swarovski and it's
silver crystals I want my light crystals
and mind you this isn't the only crystal
image that we see in dr. strange either
with strange
practicing alone in this chamber the
first thing he magically forms is you
guessed it a crystal wall no accident
Marvel did their homework on this one I
don't know about you but knowing a
little bit more about the science behind
these seemingly magical moments makes me
appreciate the scenes in the movie a
whole lot more
it's just commendable filming guys hold
on and that finally brings us to the
moment that we've all been waiting for
how do they get those cities to topple
over one another in a strictly
scientific way the key here is to listen
to what the ancient one tells Doctor
Strange when they first meet me honish
Fuji she claims that there are two keys
to their powers harnessing energy which
they do via photons and then secondly
shaping reality this is a very careful
choice of words the ancient one doesn't
say that she changes reality just that
she's shaping it
thus reality doesn't change only your
perception of it does it's the essence
of a magic trick from the vantage point
of the audience the bunny really does
come out of the Hat the car disappears
in midair and the woman is cut into
Criss Angel gets paid to do whatever
Criss Angel does the magician has shaped
reality so the audience is led to
believe and the impossible so how do you
shape reality to create upside down in
sideways cities the key here is in the
Marvel logo which for dr. strange looks
like a pattern you'd see in a
kaleidoscope right well you are right
the patterns you see in a kaleidoscope
are one version of water known as
fractal fractals are basically geometric
patterns that infinitely repeat
themselves at smaller and smaller sizes
think of a snowflake and how the same
shape is repeated over and over in every
section of the flake well marvel is
dropping hints all over the place that
fractals power the universe of Doctor
Strange popping up all over the movies
trailer when Doctor Strange enters the
Ancient Ones layer he steps across a
platform modeled after a t-square one of
the most famous recurring fractal
patterns in history the light month
allow the ancient one first shows dr.
strange yet another fractal repeating
circular images even the roof above
Strange's head in the scene where he
wields his light whip is a fractal and
it's these images that serve as the
biggest clue as to how dr. strange pulls
off his greatest trick because you know
what else creates naturally occurring
fractals crystals we already know that
strange
crystals create repeating images as we
see in this scene look closely and you
see that there's not just one but
multiple benedict cumberbatch mmm
be still my nerdy Sherlock loving heart
the upside down and sideways cities are
the exact same only at a much larger
scale these cities aren't actually
upside down or sideways they only appear
that way through a refracted repeating
image within a crystal it's important to
note that the upside down and sideways
cities aren't any different from each
other their exact replicas of one
another the same buildings the same cars
the same landmarks can be found in each
city that's because there's actually
only one city only our perception has
been altered so we see multitudes of
intermingling cities this also explains
why the cities start to distort at the
edges of the image these distortions
prove that what we're looking at aren't
actual cities on top of each other but
merely reflected images of one city
reality hasn't changed only its
perception has that being said how dr.
strange can interact and battle in a
crystal refraction is perhaps a theory
best save for another day
who knows maybe they explain that one in
the movie full disclosure this is being
written and edited edited edited edited
the week before the movie comes out so I
haven't seen it yet lastly if this scene
is explained in the movie and this is
all redundant information then screw you
screw you marble thanks for not inviting
me to an early showing of the movie you
invited markiplier does he have a film
channel no who has a film channel and is
talking about your movie me giving you
lots of promotion for your movie for
free me but new the sign fight matpat
who has to rewatch Andrey watch again
the trailer a bunch of times in order to
analyze the science of the movie it's
fine not bitter hopefully they don't
explain this in the movie otherwise this
whole episode might be a moot point
could be super embarrassing for me
alright I digress let's wrap this thing
up long story long if there's one thing
this video has shown is that Kevin Feige
'aa Ridge '''l statement is a hundred
percent correct that even though we can
explain away the magic of dr. strange
using crazy quantum theories the science
behind it all is in
magical and impressive whoever the
science researcher is at Marvel props to
you man in fact you know what here
actually let me look it up I just went
on a rant about being overlooked so I'm
not gonna overlook you science
consultant for Marvel Studios Adam Frank
astrophysics professor at University of
Rochester hue sir your name may be
overlooked by the millions of moviegoers
waiting for that post-credits warm a
joke Adam but today the millions who
hopefully watch this episode will come
to know the true magician behind the
scenes and that is you so thank you Adam
Frank for bringing accurate science to
some of the world's biggest films for
that it might not win the Oscar like my
boy leo but instead let me give you the
next best thing the theorists seal of
profound work hashtag thank Frank we're
with pride Adam as you've done your part
in making the world a slightly smarter
place with science and that is pretty
darn magical but hey that's just a
theory of film theory and cut
congratulations you're now smarter about
quantum mechanics in the Marvel Universe
impress your friends with those
knowledge bombs why don't you now if you
watch this long it means you probably
like the Marvel movies and if that's the
case then you've probably really liked
the Deadpool movie based on the number
of views it got you may have even seen
my Deadpool video about how to kill the
guy in case you missed it I'm gonna
leave a link to it right here but you
know what you probably haven't seen yet
wisecracks video on the philosophy of
Deadpool which not only has one of the
most click Beatty thumbnails in the
history of youtube I mean I love you
guys but seriously bright-yellow and
click me you've done me so proud but
also has some awesome analysis of the
movie tying it to classical literature
and dissecting what it means not just
for the Marvel Universe but what
Deadpool means for the entire movie
industry these days it's incredible I
was watching this video and I'm like
yeah that is awesome that makes so much
sense which is usually a good reaction
to have when you're watching a video and
that's why I really like sharing their
stuff with you guys because I love their
videos and I think if you like this
channel you're gonna like their videos
too these are guys that deserve way more
love on their videos so please click
right here on Deadpool's left buttcheek
to check them out
Deadpool will thank you for it he'll
also enjoy you rubbing your mouse over
his left butt cheek it will be very
pleasurable to him he'll probably make
some sort of sexual innuendo anyway with
that I'm done
next week we move away from Marvel and
move on to Pixar for a wall-e theory
that will decimate you I'm excited about
it I will never watch that movie the
same way again and honestly it was my
favorite Pixar movie to begin with so
I'm excited about that one hopefully
we'll see you next week post-credits
shwarma joke i don't know what the joke
is
i once again was not invited to the
early showing so there you go